so ist 15 uhr ich habe es immer
geschafft
hier hat vollständig geklärt ein
wirklich sehr cooler beruf machte
reportage über die korona käse und
möchte auch etwas vom tagebuch sind
finde ich natürlich klasse bisschen
traurig gestern abend war es bei mir ich
habe echt so ein bisschen gebrochenes
herz gehabt und es gibt aber auch gute
nachrichten aus china an rhesusaffen
wurde nachgewiesen dass sie immun sind
und zwar nach einer woche das ist
herausragend dass mehr jetzt im video
tagebuch bei klick substanzen finden
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
politikern und dann verpasst ja nicht
irgendwo eine aktivität los geht's ja
das ist das was ich jeden morgen mache
einmal kräftig inhalieren
das senkt die entzündungswerte und die
branche also ist was für ein asthmatiker
sehr typisches erstmal aus
ja das war gestern wohl der letzte
warnschuss der bundeskanzlerin wenn die
menschen jetzt nicht langsam in die
häuser gehen dann wird es wohl eine
ausgangssperre geben
das war ja wohl eindeutig schon heute
gibt es da auch einige meldungen zum
beispiel aus bayern wo das auch ganz
konkret gesagt wird das kann also
schneller gehen als man denkt und warum
das so wichtig ist da gibt es eine
wahnsinnig gute animation bei der
washington post
die haben einfach mal simuliert wie
sieht es aus wenn man so einer infektion
freien lauf lassen würde und man sieht
wie schnell sich da alle anstecken am
anfang ganz langsam dann immer schneller
und ganz schnell sind praktisch alle
angesteckt das ist eine ex potenzial
funktion wenn man dagegen die kontakte
minimiert eben nicht rausgeht mit einem
ganz kleinen kreis von menschen nur zu
tun hat eben mutter vater tochter sohn
also enge familie nicht mit den
großeltern zum beispiel usw
dann ist die verbreitung viel viel
langsamer und das ist schon absolut
beeindruckend wie man das sehen kann und
welche wirkung es eben haben wird wenn
wir alle in den häusern sind und es gibt
ja auch eine aktion von vielen ärztinnen
und ärzte und pflegerinnen und pflegern
die sagen bitte leute stay home bleibt
zu hause macht keine corona partys das
ist wirklich das dümmste was man machen
kann es schädigt andere menschen es
bringt sie um und deshalb ja ist das
gefährlich genauso übrigens wie hamstern
da machen wir jetzt die
lebensmittelhändlern riesen aktion und
fordern die leute auch wirklich keine
hamsterkäufe zu machen weil man darf
nicht vergessen es gibt leute die können
das einfach nicht rentnerinnen und
rentner haben nicht so viel geld um
plötzlich solche großen mengen
einzukaufen und wenn dann die regale
leer sind dann haben die nichts das ist
also maximal unfair also lasst das
hamster in kaufen ja als aufgrund all
dieser ereignisse ging es mir gestern am
nicht so gut und ich hatte so eine art
nouveau service breakdown zwei gefühle
irgendwie machen sich bei mir in der
brust breit das eine
ich fühle mich hier wirklich wirklich
sicherer und entspannt und und angstfrei
aber auf der anderen seite die
nachrichten die mich hier erreichen von
draußen
die machen mich echt fertig wenn wir
gerade ein kollege kommt der aus der
schleuse was abgeholt hat und sagt hey
draußen ist das leben ging normal dann
denke ich hat da überhaupt keiner den
schuss gehört das ist doch einfach nicht
möglich das geht nicht
und wenn ich dann die nachrichten höre
wie schlimm diese epidemie sich noch
ausbreiten kann
ich habe immer befürchtet dass es auch
so schlimm werden kann
aber ich hatte doch immer die hoffnung
das ist eben nicht so schlimm wird dass
die politik das die medizin die
wissenschaft schnell genug räder
reagiert und als ich mich hier
vorbereitet habe habe ich immer hin und
her bin ich immer hin und her schneien
wird nicht so schlimm ist das ja du bist
total übertrieben du bist total
übertrieben
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn sich so
doll vorzubereiten und du bist der
einzige der das macht bau macht kein
anderer
und jetzt in der krise denke ich
verdammt es tritt das schlimmste was
passieren kann und es wird ja immer
schlimmer als wenn so schreckliche große
fehler gemacht wie das leute plätze von
denen sie wissen wie in österreich dass
die infektionen ungebremst weiter
getragen werden einfach offen lassen
der mensch zeigt sich hier echt als als
unwürdig auf diesem planeten zu leben
und ja da hat man dann manchmal so ein
bisschen
ja es ist nicht gut das zu sagen aber
das fühlt sich an wie eine gerechte
strafe für uns und das ist tragisch und
wir müssen einfach darüber nachdenken
hey klimawandel es kann doch nicht so
weitergehen wir können doch nicht die
welt die schöpfung so brutal
vergewaltigen
weil das ist die quittung die wir jetzt
bekommen und vielleicht ist der letzte
wink mit dem zaunpfahl und wir müssen
einfach und wenn ich dann politiker höre
die sagen die welt wird danach eine
andere sein
ja sie wird eine andere sein aber
vielleicht anders als ihr euch das
vorstellen
wir müssen anders miteinander leben so
zerstören wir alles wie kann man das tun
es ist wirklich also ist es viele hört
sich jetzt etwas bricht mir wirklich
wirklich das herz ja und dann gestern
abend hier eine mail von einer
produktionsfirma die für arte reportage
macht über die korona krise und der
regisseur
er rief mich dann heute vormittag an
trachten hallo hallo david künstler
wären mir geht's gut im moment weiß ich
ich weiß gar nicht was ihr machen wollte
[Musik]
über kronach bin zu allen schandtaten
bereit
ich finde ja dass gerade also man muss
bericht erstatten bericht erstatten
bericht erstatten damit man auch ein
gegengewicht gegen die fake news bildet
das ist ja auch wirklich was total
erschreckendes und deswegen kann sich
das nur unterstützen das waren da ganz
viel macht und die leute viel erfahren
und umso mehr sie eben auch aus dem land
erfahren was los ist und ihren kleinen
horizont verlassen können durch
berichterstattung umso besser ist das
ich kriege ich habe ja mein horizont ist
ja total beschränkt ich kriege nur durch
erzählungen mit oder ich rede man mit
dem fenster aus dem fenster mit den
nachbarn darüber was so los ist aber
ansonsten kritik mit ich weiß nicht wie
voll es draußen auf den straßen ist oder
raster lösen
sehr gerne bis dann mit ja und dann gute
nachrichten aus china
dort hat man versuche gemacht mit
rhesusaffen und hat getestet ob sie
antikörper gegen saas kopf 2 bilden und
das ja verblüffende ergebnis so äußerte
sich jedenfalls der chefgeologe der
charité hier in berlin christian drosten
dass sie schon nach einer woche
antikörper gegen das virus gebildet
hatten ja und dann hat man sich das noch
genauer angeguckt also ob auch die
symptome bei den affen allein affe war
an einer lungenentzündung erkrankt
ähnlich sind wie beim menschen
das bestätigte sich auch und rhesusaffen
sind auch tatsächlich den menschen sehr
ähnlich das heißt das kann wirklich
bedeuten dass die ergebnisse dieser
studie auf den menschen übertragbar sind
und das würde bedeuten und das ist die
wirklich gute nachricht das sehr schnell
eine immunität aufgebaut wird
und umso mehr menschen sich dann halt
langsam anstecken das tempo ist wichtig
haben wir ja am anfang gesehen ja umso
desto schneller ist dann auch eine
immunität da und umso langsamer
verbreitet sich die krankheit anders
sieht das im moment und das ist wirklich
auch wieder so eine wirkliche nachricht
wo man verzweifelt dran
die spring break partys in den usa
scheinen in vollem umfang zu laufen
dh in einem land wo man überhaupt nicht
weiß wie viele menschen schon infiziert
sind wird der virus jetzt so richtig
verbreitet und ja ich hab's ja gezeigt
wie wahnsinnig die effekte dann nur aus
einer apres ski papa in diesem fall sein
und das dann ganz über europa zu
unmengen an infizierten führt also die
entwicklung ist weiter so mittel gut
und bevor ich mich verabschiede auf
spektrum video gibt's noch ein video das
ich nur empfehlen kann
zehn dinge die ihr über das neue krone
virus wissen solltet also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran